Практичні заняття з сільського господарства
від німецьких аграріїв.
За 100 кілометрів від Києва,
у Васильківському районі
німець Александер Цайн показує,  що буде з буряками,
якщо навесні проорати поле неякісно:
Ось тут занадто твердо і ґрунт працює неефективно.
А ось про ці буряки навесні добре подбали
і з цієї частини поля буде хороший врожай.
Навчання полягає у тому,
щоб мотивувати людей не просто
з вікна машини дивитися, чи поле зелене.
Треба брати лопату в руки і перевіряти,
що саме із ґрунтом, які це матиме наслідки.
Александер один з кількох німецьких фахівців,
які працюють в німецько-українському "Агарному
демонстраційному та навчальному центрі".
Його створили в 2016-ому році.
Поля німцям надав один з аграрних університетів.
Сучасну техніку - німецькі фірми.
Студентам тут на практиці і в реальному часі
показують майже всі етапи вирощування культур.
Олег Стадник закінчив Аграрний університет
в Білій Церкві, але лише тут зрозумів,
наскільки ефективно можуть діяти добрива.
Якщо все робити з німецькою точністю.
По-перше, зменшити витрати на міндобрива
і більш якісно їх розкидати: рівномірнопо полю,
що в результаті дасть хороший рістрослин
А ще точність при розподілі добрива дозволить
мінімізувати шкоду довкіллю, адже зайві нітрати
не потраплятимуть у ґрунтові води.
В Німеччині існує багато подібних навчальних майданчиків.
В Україні не усі аграрні ВИШі мають
достатньо коштів на таке практичне навчання.
Федеральний уряд Німеччини вирішив допомогти Україні,
виділивши близько півтора мільйони євро на трирічну
роботу демонстраційного та навчального центру.
Подавати заявки на навчання можуть усі бажаючі.
Для студентів-аграріїв курси безкоштовні.
Для підриємців - платні.
Ми помітили, що Україна  дуже в цьому зацікавлена.
І ми намагаємося підтримати Україну, наблизити
теоретичні навчання до практики.
І таким чином ми підтримуємо
український аграрний сектор.
Німецькі технології дозволяють без додаткових
витрат збільшити врожайність на 30%.
Тож німецькі аграрії переконані в тому, що  Україна
має усі шанси стати однією з провідних аграрних
країн, якщо підійти до справи правильно - по-німецьки.